there definitely is a relationship
between money and happiness but it's a
pretty small one so like for example
doubling your income consistently has
about the effect same effect on
unhappiness so going from forty thousand
to eighty thousand dollars a year has
the same effect of going from four
million to eight million dollars a year
so basically you're in this kind of
treadmill where you need to keep on
raising it by more and more to get a
happiness boost
dude your new book is absolutely awesome
this is this is what people want someone
that has access to loads of data to
actually come up with and do it's like
look just just tell me how i'm supposed
to live my life please can you just give
me the money ball for my existence that
would be great thank you
yeah that was the motivation for the
book is that i it's legitimately the
book i wanted to read because i'm
obsessed with self-help like it's a
little embarrassing because i'm supposed
to be such an intellectual and my
my bookshelves are just filled with
self-help like how to get more powerful
when i was single how to date better how
to be happier how to whatever
and i'm so frustrated because i read all
these books and i'm like i just don't
believe i'm like this isn't really based
on very much you just like had an idea
and you just told me it's not like up to
the rigorous standards that i'd come to
expect from uh you know data analysis
so i'm kind of just like okay what would
actually be like what have you just
explored all the areas of life
and just said what the data tells you on
it and like
you know like uh i've also noticed that
a lot of self-help books
when they say they're evidence-based or
like science-based somebody just has a
point they want to make and they just
google some study that confirms it
and like that's not how i wrote this
book i literally had no idea what i was
saying on any of these topics i'm like i
don't know what i'm saying about dating
i don't know what i'm saying about
entrepreneurship i don't know what i'm
saying about happiness and i'm just like
gonna find the best studies and the best
data and the best whatever and then like
here that's what i'm saying now so
yeah it does make other books feel uh
in
inconsistent and insubstantial you're
like hang on a second
what what what did you say you just told
me a nice story but this is just it's
just a story that happens to fit some
eat pray love narrative that sounds nice
i think it's right i thought i think
it's also a misconception that people
just want to read stories like that's
kind of a
an idea that they tell authors you know
you just tell stories tell stories tell
stories and like everybody who's read my
book so far which i'm just gonna say
that you're supposed to say the name a
lot don't trust your gut some people
remember it but uh everyone who's read
my book has been like i've been
enthralled by the tables and the charts
oh it's just like not again that's not
usually what you put in self-help books
like tables and charts dude seduced by a
nice bar chart that's what that's what
people needed
needed i think people are like people
are like coming back with like very
subtle points like the you know whatever
i'm like wow the closest everybody was
reading the book was actually the tables
and charts and and figures and i'm like
oh i think i think there were
misconceptions about like the cell about
the audience for books and what they
actually want and i think people do want
things that are a little meatier and a
little more substantial and like a
little more you know data driven so i
think a big reason for that is because
it is quite counter to
much of what gets put out there there's
a guy called stephen cutler who runs the
flow research collective and he looks at
the um science of getting your body into
a flow state but he looks at it from a
biological level right this isn't a
philosophical level this isn't how it
contributes to your meaning it's what is
the actual brainwave state you're
supposed to be in what does this mean
for your heart rate what does this mean
for your respiratory rate what does this
mean for your average body temperature
what are the exercises and the
strategies that you can do to influence
yourself to move you toward that so and
you're like it felt meaty is a really
nice way to put it you're reading this
book and you're like yeah there's
something firm for me to press up
against here and i think yeah i i think
that finding something firm as in the
data is a a good place to to look so you
decided off the back of said
book to
do a
nerdy makeover a dated
makeover i'm not following the advice
though because
uh i'm too i'm i'm dear cider whichever
on your side is that you can't see far
away so yeah so i did this analysis
there's all this evidence i didn't know
about it until i started researching
this book on how much your
looks influence
your
success in life
uh so like it's really depressing and
dark like they show pictures of two
candidates uh
you know gubernatorial elections senate
candidates and they're like which one
looks more competent and this is
researched by this guy alex todorov and
others and 70 of the elections they can
predict just just based on the candidate
who said people said look more confident
wins and it's just like that is so
depressing like what like we're all in
high school basically we can't we've
never escaped high school and then he's
done studies like who rises to the top
of the military if people just look
dominant and they're like oh there have
been studies that baby that uh people
who look baby-faced like are more likely
to get off their crop like not be
convicted of the crime you're kidding me
because i was like no yeah no not come
on not that guy
and i'm just like are you kidding me
i was reading this i was getting like
angry and angry but then i'm like wait a
second there was this other study
where they said that the same person can
be rated very differently based on like
little changes they make
so i'm like wait a second instead just
whining about how like
you know unfair it is you got to take
advantage of this you got to like find
your best look and i i use this tool uh
yeah it's a the
probably the world's nerdiest makeover
uh
face app is this like app everyone can
play around with it you can kind of
change around what happens when i have
glasses what happens when i have long
hair what happens when i have a beard
what happens when i have a mustache
goatee you can just change everything
about you
and then i
asked people to rate like how i look how
confident i looked in these different
things i use this service the best way
to do it now is a site i didn't know
about photofeeler.com
anyone could do this like you can just
match what i did so you go to face app
you create different words yourself you
go to photofeeler.com and you can get
ratings on them on how you look on
various dimensions
and then for me there were these like
really clear patterns that everyone made
me way more confident when i had a beard
and had glasses
uh
it was just like stark it was like
striking lesson anything striking the
day and everything else i did didn't
matter like oh you can add like a smile
uh different smiles no difference
different types of glasses no real
difference like
even when i shaved my head it wasn't
even that much worse uh which i may be
heading towards because i'm going bald
so that was encouraging i'm like thank
god i'm like what if i'm like a six on
confidence and then with the shaved head
i'm like a two and then i'm really
screwed because baldness is coming
faster to me uh so
or i guess if i based on that then i
would have gotten like a hair transplant
i guess uh but i'm just like oh there
are these two things glasses and beard
and they're just the huge difference
makers for me why did you want to why
did you want to optimize for competence
well
i say because like
i i tested a few of them and they were
all they're all pretty highly correlated
so like i said now that i'm happily in a
relation if i was single i'd go
attractiveness 100
i think i didn't go for attractiveness
too because i was too scared of the
results i'm like what happens if i put
it in there and everyone's like euro 0.1
i'm like oh god i'm gonna really get in
my head
whereas like i'm confident maybe like
i'll do a little better i look a little
nerdy everyone will be like you're
you're confident but i think
uh you know i i did i focused on
confidence more because i'm in a really
happily in a relationship i feel like i
don't really need to win over
you know people with attractiveness and
then i was talking to someone uh steven
levitt the co-author of freakonomics and
i told him this and he's like no no that
is your first mistake you always need to
keep the attractiveness high if you're a
partner don't get don't don't get uh you
know lazy on the attractiveness front
just because you're in a relationship
uh
but it was like it was it's very clear
data i really think everyone can do this
like initially i had to use these tools
because i didn't know about photo feeler
i just found out about that recently but
literally face app plus photo feeler
anybody could do what i did like really
really simply and photo feeler also does
a whole bunch of different traits so
they do competence and smart and like
all kinds of different things you get it
back really quickly so i bet you
everybody will find out these little
things like i did like it's just beard
and glasses are like the game changers
oh you think that's for everybody that
all of the women should have beard and
glasses as well that's just a universal
panacea across the board that every
woman get yourself
no i think the point is that it's like
the point is they're obviously going to
be individual variation that's why you
got to do the study so there are some
people that are going to do well you
know i think glasses on and confidence
may be pretty close to universal
uh we are just so tricked by glasses
and like everybody just looks smarter
when they have a pair of glasses on uh
but
uh you know but like beard i think
there's something about my face
that i think is just like
a beard like kind of
i have like a full mouth i think a beard
kind of covers it there are some like
men particularly that beards are just
like very good on like james harden the
basketball player i'm always like why is
this guy this crazy beard and then i saw
pictures before he had a beard and he's
like missing a chin dude have you seen
do you know kazma chimayev do you know
who that is
so he is one of these
he's an absolute animal in the
middleweight division in the ufc
and this guy is there's multiple series
of videos talking about how he's a
legitimate psychopath on youtube with
and he's like everyone loves him for the
fact that he's just ready to go at all
times and if you want to go and have a
laugh google kazmachimayev without a
beard and it is he is missing a chin
there is no chin there it is it is
simply a beard growing out from his neck
and you're like [ __ ] dude he's so much
more intimidating with a beard than with
that one so he's optimizing for
intimidation you were optimizing for
competence
absolutely
when i did attractiveness beard was got
me a higher score as well so i think
their their confidence and
attractiveness are very highly
correlated uh usually the things usually
like a look is better on on like every
front it's not like there's
you're usually not trading off like
you know one or the other usually like
there's a look for you i think it's
pretty clear that glasses and and beard
is my
uh is my
look uh
what were the big lessons that you
learned from data about being successful
in dating then
there are like a lot of different
lessons uh
there are okay so one of them is from
i i love this people may have heard of
it but i if you haven't you need to know
it uh christian rudder wrote this
excellent book data clism and he made
the point that the most successful
daters
are like
the the very most successful daters are
exactly who you'd expect they're like
brad pitt and natalie portman just
beautiful people and they just get like
it's depressing how much better they do
than the average person uh like uh but
then like there are these
there are these daters that do
shockingly well and they're people with
extreme looks
like people who shave their head
like what heterosexual women who shave
their head or have crazy glasses or blue
hair or all these things and the point
is in dating you want to be polarizing
so if you're brad pitt or natalie
portman you just want to be yourself and
not scare anybody just like play it very
safe
let the goodies flood to you but if you
are not natalie poorman or brad pitt or
you're not like conventionally the most
attractive person you got to kind of
lean into some extreme version yourself
and then
some people will be totally turned off
but some people will be really into you
and
that's kind of what's that's all that
matters you just need some people who
are really into you and i kind of did
that my own life because
i think it's not going to surprise
anybody that
like i'm pretty nerdy i mean anybody
read don't trust your gut would be like
this guy's pretty nerdy like uh
there's this one study where they list
the happiest they have a chart with the
happy how much happiness every activity
gives people and i literally ordered an
iphone
case with that chart on it so i can look
at the data when i'm deciding what to do
things so i'm like the nerdiest like i'm
maybe one of the nerdiest people
you know anybody's encountered and i
think when i was single
like a lot of nerds i'm like well what
do i do to you know i'm heterosexual to
you know attract women
and
i'm like okay well i gotta you know tone
it down be less nerdy
uh be you know like you know get rid of
the glasses get
get like you know stop talking about the
charts and the tables and the math and
like you know learn talk more about uh
what you're
you're taught that uh the average woman
is into and i think the data suggests
the exact opposite like nerd it up go
all in on who you are and then you'll
just be polarizing but you don't in
dating you don't want to be like average
to people you want to be like the
extreme something that's uh the most
the most appealing well because you're
not optimizing for total area under the
curve are you you only need a couple of
winners
and yeah and exactly and you know well i
like how you think a couple of winners
are exactly gonna have a variety right
i'm monogamous so i was just looking for
one winner but
uh
but i yeah and my uh girlfriend
literally she was
uh talking to her friends and they're
like what's your type and everyone's
going through their type like tall dark
and handsome this that and she's like my
type is nerdy
like that was her type
and she's not even that dirty herself
her type was nerdy and then you know and
here i am if i had not played off my
dirtiness i wouldn't have had a chance i
think the
the thing that the other big dating
thing
is you've got to put yourself out there
way more
uh so they've done these studies
on like what happens when people have
different
attractiveness or desirability ratings
message someone else on on an online
dating site
it's like what happens when a one
message is 10 on an online dating site
and before i saw the data
i'm like this is a bloodbath this is
like a one asking out of ten i mean or
investing time we're talking about like
uh one in a million a one in a billion
like come on like that that's not gonna
happen
and
the data says
for a heterosexual man one asking out a
heterosexual 10 it's like
14
and for a heterosexual woman asking out
one ass going after a heterosexual man
it's like 30
so like when you actually do the math
the key to getting like if you if you
want to date out of your league which i
don't necessarily recommend because i
also have a section how
physical conventional attraction is most
overvalued
thing in the in the day market but let's
be honest everybody's trying to
like everybody is curious how can i date
someone who's way more beautiful or way
more desirable than me
and i think it's a combination of being
an extreme version of yourself and then
asking tons of people out
uh because like if you have a 14 chance
on one go then you actually do the math
if you ask like 30 people out you have
like a 98 chance
so like all you got to do is just keep
on going after and a lot of people are
gonna be like no no no no no and
eventually
uh you're gonna get your your yes
and then they're yeah there there are
other things i could keep going there
well what was the insight around
physical attractiveness and happiness
yeah so they've done studies of like 11
000 couples and they tried to predict
what uh what predicts romantic happiness
so samantha joel led this study uh and
it's like the big it's like a
revolutionary study of romantic
happiness they've they used machine
learning models there were 86 scientists
studying it uh like 11 000 couples they
had hundreds of variables like anything
you could could consider a test and the
first thing is it's very hard in general
to predict who's happy like the
predictive models are just way worse
than you might imagine it's not like
uh
predicting
i don't know predicting like
the weather tomorrow or something it's
like predicting the weather in like
three years
like it's it's it's harder than you than
you'd guess
but that said
the things that matt that do have at
least some predictive power whether
whether i'm happy with someone else
whether a particular person has someone
else the qualities the other person that
seemed to have some predictive power
are like these psychological variables
so secure attachment style growth
mindset conscientiousness satisfaction
with life
uh kind of like
good
psychological variables and the things
that don't have that have like basically
no predictive power are a lot of
superficial things so conventional
attractiveness
or the height of your partner uh the
particular occupation of your partner uh
many things like that and so all of the
things that online apps optimize for on
the front end yeah yeah so like so yeah
so
it's it i think like the mate the major
insight from the data on
dating and romance is there's just a
total disconnect between what people are
trying to
like what people are swiping for or
trying to
uh
date and what actually makes people
happy
uh you know will people change based on
knowing that i don't know
i think it may be coded in our dna that
we're drawn to like beauty and you know
height and status and
uh but
like if i if you can i really do
recommend
uh overruling some of those instincts
because they're really not a path
uh to long-term happiness and
like the other thing is you have to
think is that
the competition for these traits is so
enormous
that like even if you win over someone
like
if you if you win over someone who is
this you know great beauty or a woman
everybody every woman's they're i think
the data is
85 of women or i don't remember the
exact number have like
six foot or above on bumble or whatever
it is it's something i think is only 14
of men in the u.s
yeah yeah and it's like
and like
uh
so the competition for these people are
wrote or is ferocious and you have to
think that if you
first of all
if you try to take these people
you may spend a huge percent of your
life single and complaining that you're
single like i think a lot of people who
are perpetually single they're trying to
date
the small number of people that
everybody's trying to date
uh
and number two
if you do win them over
you may find that
they are
like that there's a reason that they
were single even though they have all
these traits that everybody is desiring
so maybe their psychological traits are
a little bit
uh subpar i would love to see i would
love to see the um physical
characteristics mapped with the
psychological traits you know what are
the correlates between are taller people
on average more conscientious and more
industrious so yeah more balanced
because that would be fascinating to see
because it it could be
it actually could be that in order to be
with someone who's hot you need to
sacrifice being with someone who's
psychologically it's probably not likely
right they're probably pretty just
randomly spread but that could be the
case
i think if you're not hot and you want
to date someone hot then you probably do
have to sacrifice yeah
so if you're like
if you're hot yourself then you're
probably like okay you're probably you
know it's probably it's somewhat of a
market uh you're probably in in better
in better you can always
date across and down yeah well the
interesting thing there is what what
you're kind of saying is similar to what
john burgess says in uh make the first
move
where
it's it's it's not lowering your
standards
it's changing what your standards
consist of because what you're saying is
that what you think your standards
should be aren't what they should be
you're optimizing for the wrong
parameters what you're optimizing for is
something like height and job title and
a bunch of things which aren't going to
impact the thing that you ultimately
want which is long-term relationship
happiness what you need to do is reset
that and by doing that you actually open
up an entire new market which is less
competitive potentially untapped and
significantly more linear between where
you are and where you want to be in
terms of happiness
but nobody wants to hear that advice
[ __ ] dating advice how do i get the hot
person how do i get the phone how do i
get the fittings i told you the way to
get the hot person is to be an extreme
version yourself and ask out lots of
people and the oh the other thing i
didn't say
is take advantage of similarity
so
uh
people are incredibly drawn this is also
shown in date in uh dating apps to
people who are similar to themselves
like on every trait you can imagine so
race people are drawn to people are
similar themselves uh religion
uh
like heightened height to some degree uh
even like college people don't just want
to date someone of a similar education
level they like show a bonus to someone
who went to their exact same university
uh even if it's like relative to someone
in a so similar ranked university
uh that you know there's and then oh my
favorite example of this is
we're 11.3 percent more likely on online
dating
apps to match with someone who shares
our initials
uh which is so ridiculous like come on
initials like sharing your initials is
not the path to long-term happiness
but
so so i think there's a lot of
irrationality in that but you can take
advantage of that in that try like if
you share your initials with someone
definitely ask them out because you have
this bonus
all right you've got like the multiplier
that's the 11.4 percent multiplier on
that oh well she's a she's a 9 out of 10
but she does have my initials so if i
take that she's actually only re she's
like a
a parameter adjusted eight and a half
with when we account for the the name
bias
but yeah and i think i learned this in
my single life
where i am jewish
and
but i'm not religious at all and i
always pride myself on not caring about
uh
religion like i would be happy to date
somebody of any religious background any
cultural background whatever it's not
something that i view is very very
important to me
but i did kind of notice
that the quality of my dates were always
higher with the jewish community than
the non-jewish community because of this
similarity bias so even if i don't care
like even if it's not a preference for
me
i can take advantage of the fact that
it's a preference for other people and i
should probably be more likely to go to
like a singles event for jewish people
than a singles event for non-jewish
people because in the non-jewish singles
event i'm going to be a five or whatever
but yeah jewish jewish privileged man
the jewish privilege and the jewish
it's chinese privilege in the chinese
event it's asian privilege in that yeah
i understand yeah
and it's like it's true for asian
males as well they're i talk about the
there's a huge prejudice against asian
males in online dating uh but there's
much less pr prejudice from asian women
in this
in this group so yeah it's it's a
privilege that
like
you know yeah
again my major advice is care less about
these superficial things and just try to
find someone who's like really nice and
could make you happy and if you can get
to that mindset
you're going to find dating
way way easier
but
if you want to date like a hot person
then you have to use all these
strategies and and everything that i
think are justified the data use your
privilege uh is is one of them
what about what makes people happy then
you looked at that
yeah so
uh
what makes people happy i've
i
there's i i've read like a thousand
studies on happiness and a lot of them
even ones that are really famous
i'm like
these studies aren't that good they like
interview like 100 undergraduate
students and they're like so what makes
you happy i'm like
like how should i know that these
hundred undergrad students or anything
like anybody else you you're not like
doing experiments it's just was very
underwhelming
but there are these new projects which
are really cool they're called
experience sampling projects
and they basically ping people on their
smartphones
and they say
who what are you doing who are you with
and how happy are you and they built a
data set of like three million happy
points the biggest one mappiness george
mccarron susan dorado three million
uh data points
and
there are all these cool sites that i
get so excited because i just as i said
very very nerdy so i'd like read one of
these studies they're like people are
happier the same person do the same
activities same people are happier when
they're in nature by a lake where
they're happier when their environment
is beautiful or their happiest going for
a hike or having sex is the number one
happy activity and i'm kind of like
i was telling my friends as i was
working on the chapter and i'm like you
know did you hear about this cool study
and they're like do we need scientists
to tell us this
like that's so obvious like all these
things that you're saying
are painfully obvious
and i think there's profundity in the
obviousness of the research on happiness
uh which is that
the things that make you happy like if
you look i have the happiness activity
chart from alex bryce and george
mccarron in one of my and that's what i
recommend people get as an iphone case
or hang it on your wall or whatever
and you look at that chart it's almost
like a chart from our hunter-gatherer
days it's like
people are
happy like you know yeah having sex
taking walks hunting and fishing
gardening like just like these very
outdoor simple activities and the things
that are really low are these like very
modern things like waiting on a line
uh dealing with a bureaucracy working
uh
internet social media very very low
computer games really really low when
you actually ping people how happy are
they they rank very low
i think it's good to keep in mind like
the simplicity of the things that make
people happy and if you're not happy
oh i end the book i say what's the
data-driven answer to life uh based on
these three million you know happiness
points and and all this this new data
and i go the data-driven answer to life
is to be with your love on an 80-degree
and sunny day
overlooking a beautiful body of water
having sex
and like which is okay not rocket
science it's not like they
you know scientists have found
some like gel you put on yourself or
some website you visit that's like the
cure to happiness it's these very
old-fashioned simple things
and i do recommend
to people who are not happy
like think about how far your life is
from that those simple things that from
the data driven ads for life so like
how much time are you spending in nature
how much time you're spending on the
internet in comparison uh how much time
are you spending with the people who
make you happy are friends and romantic
partners and like everybody else just
doesn't make you happy you had to
you had a list of underrated activities
the things that tend to make people
happier than they'd predict
exhibitions museums libraries sports and
exercise drinking alcohol gardening and
shopping or errands and then the
overrated activities that make people
less happy than they think sleeping
resting relaxing computer games watching
tv eating and browsing the internet i'm
surprised and i was really surprised
when i looked at the list of activities
that playing with pets wasn't higher
it's like maybe 15 i think but dude if
you put a dog in this room i'm not doing
anything for the rest of the day like
that's me that's me and the dog someone
oh you want to have some sex it's like
no sorry i'm with the dog at the moment
so again there's individual variation in
this
having sex with the person that no don't
do that so um drinking alcohol was an
interesting one and i think that you
talk about this it's not necessarily
just about what the activity does but
it's about what you're doing while
you're in the activity right so drinking
alcohol is often associated it's like
socializing you're spending time with
friends you're having a conversation
maybe you're also at a show or a comedy
event or watching a gig or something
like that
yeah i mean drinking alcohol what you're
getting with the pet example is there
probably is individual variation in
these and you don't have to
although i think a danger with happiness
is we exaggerate how much individual
variation there is so there have been
studies where they've they've compared
introverts and extroverts and they say
how much happier they are when they're
by themselves
or with other people
and both introverts and extroverts get
the exact same boost from being with
other people than being by themselves
even though if you ask introverts
they're like yeah yeah you know i really
like being by myself i really like being
by myself so i think there's a danger
like i
i'd be
i'd be a little wary if i were you like
i'd ask you to actually track your
happiness and see if you're getting as
much happiness from pets as you might
think because i think we do tell
ourselves these stories tell ourselves
these stories
that are
not always
correct and and that we're like unique
and
uh so i i i don't know i i mean yeah i i
think there's also different time stem
with pets so sometimes like if you're
just like
you know like
uh yeah like petting them playing catch
with them that's one thing if you're
cleaning up their
crap
well you've got it it's got to be spread
across time right one thing that i
thought that was interesting is there a
tension between happiness and meaning so
there's this roy baumeister study the
paper that you've probably read about
the tension that you have between these
two different things and there's a lot
of things that we can do in the moment
which makes us feel happy sort of more
on the hedonic side but long term
doesn't necessarily create meaning did
you think about this i did like i think
uh
yeah you know like for example work
score is very low on happiness and i
think you know i don't know the answer
from that is just quit your job and
yeah live in nature
living yeah i don't i don't and and you
know the the study that i referenced
mappiness uh isn't following people over
three years and being like
you know
you see kind of the in the moment
happiness and you don't necessarily see
as much the uh you know the long-term
things
i do think it's just
it's just
i think from these studies
you just can nudge yourself a little bit
uh in the direction of things that make
people happy that that's kind of wise
without sacrificing everything that's
meaningful to you so don't you know uh
you know if you if you
read uh you know my don't trust your god
or you read these studies uh i don't and
and then yeah you immediately quit your
job and move to a lake like i'd be like
that may be taking the advice a little
too
uh seriously i you know i
i
think think more clearly but anybody who
reads these studies and then
the next weekend is deciding between
sitting at home and playing computer
games
or going for a walk with your friends by
the water
and it is kind of uncertain
like i'd really recommend you went with
your friends on the walk by the water
uh just based on the data so
what did social media use due to
people's happiness you looked at that in
depth yeah yeah so so there so up in the
mappiness study
the single there are 26 leisure
activities
the single lowest
scoring leisure activity is using social
media
uh which already says wow that's
probably not so good for you and there
have been there was a famous randomized
controlled trial where they paid people
to stop using facebook
they randomly paid a group of people to
stop using facebook and they report an
enormous decline in depressive symptoms
so i think there really is pretty it's
almost a cliche to say it but there
really is evidence that social media can
make people miserable for the obvious
reason that
uh
it's makes you feel like crap about your
life uh you
uh you know if you're seeing on facebook
like the curated version of everybody
else's
life
uh i actually my first book everybody
lies i talk a lot about that and the
difference between like
social media and real life and google
searches and on uh social media when
people describe their husbands
it's my husband is the best the greatest
so cute and adorable
and that's like public everyone's seeing
it and when it's on when they're
searching my husband is it's like my
husband is a jerk annoying mean uh like
a totally different view not having sex
with me
not having sex with me yeah uh so
uh there's so like social media like
it's a cliche to say it but it's just so
true it really is a dangerous
uh game to play uh from from a happiness
perspective why do you think it is that
we're so bad at working out what makes
us happy
well i think the world's trying to trick
us
like there are people i mean social
media we're up against forces more
powerful than we are which are doing all
these a b tests to try to make the most
addictive
uh products possible
and
like you know i talk about money and
happiness and there definitely is a
relationship between money and happiness
but it's a pretty small one
uh so like for example there's a study
by matthew killingsworth
doubling your income consistently has
about the effect same effect on
unhappiness so going from 40 000 to
eighty thousand dollars a year has the
same effect of going from four million
to eight million dollars a year has the
same effect going from
you know like so basically you're in
this kind of treadmill where
uh you need to keep on raising it by
more and more to get a happiness boost
uh
now of course like
i sound like a conspiracy theorist and
these ideas are almost so cliche but
they're just true
you know advertisements don't want you
to think that money doesn't matter they
want you to think that you need
uh you know fan you know you need the
fanciest products and
uh so they're kind of
they're they're they're kind of telling
you brainwashing you a little bit uh on
the things that that will make you happy
that you know there are also been
studies that
uh the purchases that make people happy
and it's very rarely stuff it's usually
vacations travel uh gives the biggest
boost to happiness when you kind of ask
people what are you doing and how happy
you are and what what product are you
using uh the only products that really
are giving people happiness are trips uh
and
other experiences uh frequently with
their romantic partner or their friends
like museums tours
stuff like that yeah so so things like
that could legitimately give you a
heaviest boost they're usually not even
that expensive uh but when people are
using a fancy new electronic
uh or you know
wearing an armani suit they're not
really getting a big happiness boost so
i think that's an example why are we
wrong well
like armani probably spends more time
advertising than like that than uh the
grand canyon does
uh so
uh you know like yeah if you turn on the
tv you're not really seeing many
advertisements have you thought of
taking a camping trip in the grand
canyon with your friends uh because
grand canyon is a non-profit they're not
even making money uh so
uh it's it's it's they're yeah so i
think we're getting kind of uh the wrong
messages about uh the path to happiness
what is it there was that famous study
that said above 70 000 a year
money has no impact on happiness it
seems like what you're saying here is
that that's
[ __ ]
it's not true but it's
it's it's true in that
the effects level off a lot so it's not
literally true that you reach 75 000
then money doesn't improve things at all
uh but
going from
uh you know forty thousand to eighty
thousand is the same as going from
eighty thousand two hundred sixty
thousand so
it's it does it it is leveling off it's
just it doesn't level off to zero there
is also some evidence that like once you
reach about eight million dollars you
also get a boost
uh and i think the what's that
i think the reason for that is that
then you're reaching a point and i've
started since i've moved to new york
i've
met a lot of people
in that camp of 8 million and well
beyond
uh and i think they're at a level where
they
literally have everything taken care of
them for them and you see the happiness
activity chart uh that that included
don't trust your gut and like there are
all these miserable activities you know
standing on lines
uh work housework uh housework like they
really don't make people happy and when
you reach eight billion dollars uh net
worth or beyond you don't have to spend
much of your life doing those things
that's the point of which the driver or
the assistant can stand in line for you
when the chef can cookie breakfast when
the housekeeper can clean up blah blah
yeah and then you really can spend most
of your life just
by a beach having sex
in 80 degree weather all right so
talking about people that have stupid
amounts of wealth what's the best way to
become rich
so i actually there's this study i read
again most times i read a study i'm just
like
that's
like i don't believe the study or i'm
like it's like they make these subtle
points you know like if you read any
academic study like usually they're just
like making these very subtle
interactions like theoretical point that
only the researcher you care about but
occasionally you read a a
sentence a study that kind of blows your
mind and i've read the studies from the
entire universe of taxpayers american
taxpayers and they analyzed who's in the
top point one percent so it's people
making
uh 1.5 million dollars a year so these
are people approaching the level where
you can't actually just be happy with
how much money you have and
they said that the typical rich american
is
the owner of a
regional business such as an auto
dealership or beverage distributor
and i read that i'm just like what like
who thinks of an auto dealer owner like
auto dealers just like these annoying
like people with greasy suits who try to
sell us like things we don't need you're
not really thinking of them as like
rich people and then beverage
distributor i didn't even know what that
was
uh and
it turns out that
uh so like the the likely so there are a
couple points this one is you have to
own something
to get rich by and large so like if you
look at the richest americans members of
the top point one percent i think about
84 of them are making their money
primarily by owning something not by
paying paid a salary so there are some
people who are just like get paid a ton
of money superstar lawyers maybe or
stuff like that yeah yeah yeah so you
know occasionally but usually if people
are owning something
uh and then
you want to have like some sort of
a good and then you want to go on a good
field so all these fields that are awful
uh they've done studies the quickest
field businesses like that go out of the
business the field where the business
goes out of uh business quickest and
like number one was record store uh the
average record store lasts 2.5 years
uh in comparison the average dentist's
office lasts 19.5 years and basically
the problem is everybody wants to own a
record store they're all these movies
made about record stores uh like there
have been a whole bunch of record store
movies i think probably every time some
that movie comes out everyone's like i'm
going to quit my job and start a record
store and
it's just like not a good path and
like toy store is an awful business
clothing stores awful business
uh uh there's some other ones and
but then there are things you basically
want a local you want a local monopoly
where like so auto dealerships
there they have like legal protections
where you kind of have franchise rights
to service a particular
uh car company in your local region
and that's a big advantage in business
if you have legal protections about
against some
random person coming in and stealing
your business and i think
now so i think you can't really read
this
this that and say okay now i'll just
start a local dealer i'll now just start
an auto dealership because the whole
point of auto dealership is you're not
allowed to start a new one and compete
with these these people
uh but
uh
i think you want to be thinking that
principle of like what's my local
monopoly that allows
like that allows me to avoid
someone just
you know stealing my entire business or
offering a lower price or anything and
even i talk about the book that like
independent creatives
may be a better bet than i had thought
uh being kind of like what you're doing
like a podcast host or when i'm doing a
writer
and it's there are like a surprise i was
surprised by how many people
are
entering the top one percent or even the
top point one percent as independent
creatives it's still a long shot most
people aren't
but it's not like
as
big a long shot as i thought and i think
the reason for that is you have a local
monopoly so like
if chris you know as you're building
your brand
you build a fan base
and then like
everybody i could be on 20 different
podcasts well your fans are gonna listen
to your podcast and watch i you can ask
me the same questions you could be like
someone else could be you know should i
play with my pet or
uh have sex and
the exact same questions but you're
gonna have a an edge because you've
built a fan base
uh and similarly you know i've written
some books and
people i already have
like people who bought liked everybody
lies my first book and now they're gonna
give me kind of the benefit of the doubt
and
uh don't trust your guts you have you do
have this kind of a little bit of a vote
as a
creative
uh that
like
i think it's a better business than like
pest control or something
or a record store
yeah well records yeah but like even
even some boring businesses like pest
control the data says like basically
nobody's getting rich from pest control
businesses and the problem with being in
the pest control business
is
you don't you're there's no way to build
a local monopoly like you're basically
competing against everybody and
everybody's just googling for pest
control and you have to any profit you
have you're going to give away an ads
on google to try to get higher up on the
list like nobody's like you know there's
no name in pest control or there's no
there's no legal protection i really
like this seth seth's pest control
because of the personality that he
brings when he's getting rid of my
cockroaches yeah nobody yeah nobody and
and like you don't even have have that
many repeat customers anyway so there's
just like not yeah
yeah it's really hard to escape the
perfect competition that field so like
to say
competition you either need
like a legal protection a legal
protection like all of these dealerships
have
you need
like some sort of personal context being
like really deep in a field or you need
like a fan base
yeah it's a unique way to imprint a
difficult to replicate competitive
advantage and you see this with uh pts
so my old housemate louis is pt uh and
he moved
i think to two or three different gyms
in the time that he was living with me
and these gyms were three miles to one
of them and then another five miles to a
different one in around the city and i
was like dude there isn't i
felt really bad i was like what if he
loses all of his clients tons of his
clients stayed with him now hang on a
second you're talking about someone
maybe adding
two hours a week
onto their commute
just to go and train with you two or
three times and people were prepared to
go brand new facility different gym
different place different parking
different route and they stuck with him
because it's a very personal experience
right people aren't you're not just
being competed out of the market with
this very transactional sort of pest
control get rid of my cockroaches thing
it's something very very specific
speaking of online coaching
what was that analysis about the best
way to sell a product online if you were
doing like a seminar or something
yeah they did an analysis of like uh is
it called amazon live
where they where people are kind of
making a pitch try to sell their product
it was a really amazing study they used
artificial intelligence to translate all
the pitches into like the facial
expression
they analyzed the facial expression of
everyone making their pitch and they had
all kinds of other data about the pitch
and they knew how much of the product
actually sold
and they found that the best way to sell
your product
is basically a poker face so like if
you're angry or like depressed or like
sad or like you know then like yeah
everyone's just like i don't want to
watch this person but too many people
selling their products have smiles like
these goofy smiles on their face and are
too excited and that actually backfires
there's like this sweet spot where
you're not showing too much happiness or
too much sadness a poker face i think
they say the authors of study say
uh having a poker face instead of a
smile is about twice as valuable as free
shipping
so uh
which is which is kind of
counterintuitive you don't really think
like uh you know i think everybody's
instinct is be like really excited for
what you have and
i think they're you know the study
didn't get into like the the
nitty-gritty i'm sure if you were had
the poker face for like an hour everyone
would be like show me a smile like
lighten up relax show some happiness but
it does show the danger that there is a
danger in selling things of being too
excited by your product and kind of
being a little more even keeled
uh and honest uh can uh can help what
about some of the myths to do with
entrepreneurial success
oh yeah
so
entrepreneurial success there's this
famous idea that entrepreneurs are young
so like mark zuckerberg
started facebook when he was 19
uh steve jobs was 20 started apple uh
bill gates 19 we started microsoft these
are kind of the most famous
entrepreneurs in the world
and
i think people think uh they're also the
most famous entrepreneurs featured in
the media so they've done studies of the
entrepreneurs in magazines and like the
median age is 27 or something so people
just love telling the stories of these
young people when you actually look at
the data of the entire universe of
entrepreneurs
the average successful entrepreneur is
42
and the odds of an entrepreneur
succeeding
increase until the age of 60.
uh they which shocks me like you don't
think of a 60 year old like that's the
total opposite
of a successful entrepreneur and the
other and like what it turns out is
there's pretty much a formula for being
a successful entrepreneur you just get
really deep into the nitty-gritty of a
field for many many years
and then you branch out on your own when
you're ready uh which again goes against
a lot of stereotypes a lot of
stereotypes like just come from the
outside knowing nothing when you're
18 and it's not true like if you want to
be an entrepreneur the best path is like
take it slow
under learn about a field work as an
employee prove your worth as an employee
and then like learn some you'll learn
something very particular about
that field and you really know what to
do uh when you're ready so well yeah
it's it's such a compelling narrative
that outsiders edge right the elon musk
he never did a thing before so from
first principles he's gonna do whatever
and you go well yeah but the guys that
elon got to design batteries have
probably spent their entire lives
designing batteries you know he didn't
get he didn't get some dude that did
woodwork
for the last for the last 20 years and
yeah you talk about uh paul graham as
well and that
was it the marginal
marginal edge or something as well
yeah yeah power the margin all the paul
graham at this s this essay i'm a huge
paul graham family this essay like
that's an advantage to being a bad
employee because if you're a good
employee
you're not going to fit in in
entrepreneurship and it's not true in
the data at all the best entrepreneurs
like earn the in the 99.9 percentile of
income before they started their
business
uh so
uh like i think a problem a problem with
understanding how the world works
is like
some ideas are almost too compelling
that they fool us like we want them to
believe we want to believe them too much
so everybody wants to believe that
you know
oh tomorrow i can just like
wake up and design a new car or
uh
you know design some new chemical that's
gonna do something really wild or
you know there are all kinds of examples
you can imagine and it's kind of like
that's not really how the world works
uh and it's it's dangerous to think the
world works there because i think a lot
of people screw up their lives
uh you know based on some of these ideas
that's much less compelling though right
think about how sticky some of these
stories are this the stickiness of the
story about the average age of a founder
and an entrepreneur in silicon valley is
27 and a half years old or something
that's
so much more worthy of being pushed
around than it's your mid-40s because
that's what everybody would have thought
you talk about this you say it's the the
counter counter intuitive
narrative yeah it's so bizarre think
about the fact that the thing that
everybody expects to be the case work
hard in one field get
unbelievable specific knowledge then
branch out on your own once you've got
to the complete top having been a very
good employee and wait wait a long time
until you've got tons of experience like
the fact that the media has managed to
convince us that that is now a
revolutionary story
we were the idiots
but but but yeah i think but i think
like
listeners podcasts
like you can
overrule that like i think when people
have seen that they've been like oh yeah
like they've made different decisions
based on that and you can just look at
these charts and it's like something
about looking at these charts just
clears away the noise a little bit where
i'm just like okay like now i
i know that i'm just being misled by the
media and i'm gonna just look at these
charts and remind myself
uh when i get these one-off stories that
are
uh you know try like meant to confuse me
and so sticky so
uh i think you can
i i agree that it's like it's harder to
get these ideas out out there but i
think a lot of people have told me from
reading that section that they are like
adopting more of that mindset they're
not going to quit their job tomorrow and
try to do something they've never tried
before and some of them are using this
an optimistic way where there are a lot
of people
who are
45 years old they've been an employee
their entire life
uh and they've had success in that field
but they're just like i'm too it's too
late
like entrepreneurs are
you know do it in their 20 years younger
than me yeah exactly yeah like how am i
gonna compete against all these youngins
and i think
they'll be particularly drawn to the
this idea because now they can be like
well that now i gotta think about do i
wanna go off on my own and start my own
business
how can people hack look
uh
yeah so
there are all these studies
the the best way to learn about luck
is the art world
because the art world is so much luck
like they're all these
like these depressing studies of what it
takes to like of like what why a
particular piece of art is
really successful there's so much
randomness in it
uh but
there are also these patterns that allow
people to kind of allow these random
opportunities to
uh come to them so for example there
have been studies
that the quantity of art
of art someone makes is a massive
predictor of how successful they are so
just putting a lot of work out in the
world
is like a a massive predictor of success
and why is that well because there's so
much randomness in what particular work
catches on you just gotta kind of flood
the market and let luck find you uh you
know if it's if if there's a if every
piece of which piece wins is luck then i
want to be the one with a thousand
pieces not ten pieces right because i
have
uh you know 100 more opportunities to
get lucky uh and that's been found in
many many fields this idea of kind of
just putting more work into the world
and allowing yourself to get more lucky
applying to more jobs uh asking more
people out in dating
like just yeah it's it's a crap shoot
but when it's a crap shoot you want more
lottery tickets uh and the other thing
that's been found which is really cool
uh in a study of a whole bunch of
painters
uh they were trying to predict what
painter rises to the top and they're
like the biggest predictor by far
is how they present their work
and the ones who don't make it present
their work to the same place the same
gallery over and over again
and the ones who do they're like
bumblebees they're just like constantly
they're just like traveling everywhere
you i can i'll present there i'll
present their opposite there like anyone
who'll have them they go and
occasionally just stumble on some big
break uh and that's pretty profound
i think a lot of people make the mistake
of just
like not exposing themselves widely
enough uh to wait and exposing yourself
widely can dramatically increase your
chances of getting that lucky break i
was going to say what do you think is
the lesson for people that aren't
artists
i think there's probably a lot of
similarity and that uh
the the mistake of the artists who are
presenting in the same gallery over and
over again is they already didn't get
the break there so don't assume if you
haven't gotten your break there
then
you're gonna get it next year or two
years or three years uh so kind of
stagnating in a place where you're not
rising or not where nothing much good is
happening uh you gotta kind of
particularly when you're young you gotta
travel more widely uh to find uh to find
a break i would say would be the lesson
i take from it and
uh
like traveling to places where you're
more likely to get your break as well uh
you know like
uh many of the artists who didn't get
their break were
presenting in countries that
aren't known for discovering artists
and similarly many
you know
computer compute tech people aren't in
silicon valley that that may be you know
a mistake going to going to the place
where you're more likely to get a break
i think can be uh very valuable what was
that thing that you learned about the
mona lisa
oh yeah
the mona lisa i didn't realize this i
read a book vanish smile that the mona
lisa was just an ordinary painting but
then there was like
this heist
and
everybody was trying to understand what
happened
uh why the mona lisa was stolen and it
was like a worldwide phenomenon uh
people like the people thought pablo
picasso had stolen it people thought jp
morgan installed it it turned out to
just be like a low-level employee had
stolen it it was underwhelming but the
heist gave it so much attention
that now it was the most famous painting
so we everyone thinks the mona lisa is
the best painting but it's not really
it's just happened to be
uh the painting that
uh got stolen stolen in the right place
at the right time yeah but the point of
that is if you have a thousand paintings
you have more chances for one of them to
be stolen
uh you know like it's it's pretty it's
pretty clear that just working forever
to get your one piece exactly right
is not the best strategy having lots of
pieces and then allowing one of them to
get lucky is a better strategy there's
that famous uh photography class study
that was done on this as well right that
two groups were split up one was told to
take as many photos as they wanted and
then to submit one at the end the other
group was told that they needed to work
on one shot for the entirety of the
course when you compare them at the end
the group that's taken a ton of shots is
just iterated so much more effectively
and yeah
the learning by doing thing
ties back into what we were saying
before about working hard and deep one
particular field sticking at it for a
long time like the unsexy stuff what was
that thing you looked at um how to
become a good athlete if you don't have
the genetics to be one yeah it was just
i i was obsessed with sports i still am
obsessed with sports but uh i was
interested in uh but i have no i had no
talent uh hey i didn't have no talent i
was a
i i rose to be an okay high school
baseball player right but uh like i
i didn't have time it was also just as
in a county where there were no good
baseball players the loftiest of us
yeah small town high school
i was very far from being a great player
but
there's actually uh
there's actually an interesting way to
think about uh genetics the genetic edge
in sports which is uh
like if something's really genetic there
are lots of identical twins because
identical twins share a hundred percent
of their genes
uh so they're gonna be a lot more
identical twins in that sport than even
like fraternal twins or just normal
brothers or sisters
uh so like basketball is dominated by
identical twins i know it's kind of a
big stanford basketball fan and we like
suck for 10 years and then we recruit a
set of ident seven-foot identical twins
and we're great again so it's the
college twins first that was the lopez
twins it's like
it's it's it it works predictably uh it
saves our our basketball program
and
uh in the course of basketball uh
they're they're it's just like dominated
to a degree very very few other sports
are uh by identical twins which shows
that basketball's incredibly genetic in
part because height is one of the most
genetic traits and each inch doubles
your chances of making the nba uh
which is really cool like actually like
a six one person has twice the chance of
a six foot person and then a six nine
person has twice the chance of a six
eight person a seven two person has
twice the chance of seven one person
like throughout the distribution uh
that's gonna tail off at some point or
else well we don't we don't know uh
there's not a big enough sample for like
eight foot it yeah it it probably does
because i think like
beyond a certain point it's usually a
disease which massively
lowers your coordination so like a
thyroid problem
people like course
seven
five or above frequently it's a
a a thyroid a thyroid issue that leads
to that level of growth
but then
there are certain sports like
uh
they're not as exciting as being a
basketball player but like a questionism
and diving
uh we have a whole chart in them but
where there are there's like never there
have never been identical twin olympic
diving and equestrian athletes and if
you actually do the math
it's pretty clear that that means that
the genetics just aren't that big a
factor uh in those forts uh which is why
a lot of rich people kind of who had uh
kids like me who want to be athletes
they're like yeah go into equestrianism
uh and you can become a great equestrian
athlete and it's totally true there's
very little we know we know that you're
not built for athletics so let's try and
weasel you into something
but yeah diaby's interesting one too
because uh adam grant uh the professor
at warden who's written a lot of popular
books
uh he became a very talented diver
and his coaches told him
exactly what the data says that
like if you're nerdy
uh he wants to be a basketball player
and they're like you're not talented
enough but you are
very disciplined and hardworking and
passionate uh so diving is a good sport
for you
and the data totally uh you know totally
justifies that that's uh really where
you want to put your energy what did you
learn about parenting that was so this
was something that i'd seen previously
in a discussion and then to have it
brought up in the data again was so
interesting
yeah so
uh the overall effects
of parents are like ways
less than everybody thinks us and the
studies that are twins and adoptees so
if you like see
you know identical twins adopted by
different parents they turn out
shockingly similar and then
uh
and then
uh people
adopted to the same parents end up not
that similar at all but then
so like uh so
uh parents in general matter very very
little but there is evidence that the
neighborhood you live in matters a lot
uh
basically they've looked at tax records
and
uh compared
and people who grow up in certain
neighborhoods just do way better and
they've done all this clever math to
prove that it's really cause causally
certain neighborhoods are making them
better and the big uh predictor of that
interestingly
is the adults in that neighborhood so
like adults that fill out a lot of
census forms
if if you like live on a block with
adults that live fill out a lot of
census forms your kids way more likely
to have good outcomes and you're kind of
like what the hell
like that's the randomest thing in the
world it's basically like good
responsible adults
uh similarly if girls move to
neighborhoods with lots of female
scientists they're more likely to become
uh scientists themselves uh so like one
of the lessons i took from the data is
you can outsource parenting a little bit
like when you tell your kids to do
something they're just gonna probably
rebel against you because
you know a lot of people think their
parents are like
the least cool people on the planet
but
your friends they're gonna think they're
pretty cool
probably like if i think of my parents
friends all of them like yeah those are
you know there are periods where i
thought my dad was pathetic and the
biggest loser and whatever but his
friends are always like yeah
they're awesome
so basically you just gotta you just
gotta pick friends that you want your
kids to turn out to be like and put them
in front of your kids
uh and then you may be shocked by how
much an impact uh these people are
having on your kids it's so interesting
the fact that the people that you live
next door to are potentially going to
have a bigger impact on your children
than you do
yeah
yeah yeah it's weird it's wild
not even their kids right not even that
it's not don't worry about oh well such
and such his son is a he's a bit of a
naughty boy and he doesn't really listen
in class and it's like yeah but his
dad's cool as [ __ ] and he's a
millionaire go like just let little
timmy go and play with him a lot
yeah it reminds me of i don't know if
you saw the book uh
if you read the book rich dad poor dad
yeah by robert kiyosaki
yeah yeah that's exactly that
that his life was transformed by meeting
this guy
who he thought was way cooler than his
dad could it not be like cool dad uncool
dad that might just be it
yeah yeah
and yeah and then and then like that
transformed his life that instead of
kind of this traditional narrow path
that he thought he was supposed to take
of getting a lot of college degrees and
like working for the government he wants
to become an entrepreneur like his uh
his rich dad his friend's dad so i
didn't think about that well what about
that what about if his dad had been the
rich dad and his friend's dad had been
the poor dad
robert would have probably grown up to
be poor because he would have listened
to the wrong person yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's interesting to think
about i mean
yeah i don't know yeah it's it can't
exaggerate the extent of this you know
some parents definitely do have big
impacts on their kids and sometimes kids
do think their parents are really cool
but i think uh you know that i think the
parents are polarizing figures for kids
whereas like the neighbors tend to be
universally
uh kind of cool like now even looking
back on it like the parents in my
neighborhood who i know weren't cool
like when i was a kid i thought they
were really cool and cooler than my dad
like uh you know like one one guy he was
just such a show-off he wasn't even a
good basketball player but he just like
constantly be dribbling the ball between
his legs and doing like weird moves and
i'm like now looking back on him like
that guy was pathetic like trying to
impress 10 year olds with his terrible
basketball moves but at the time i'm
like this guy's amazing maybe that's why
i want to be a basketball player because
i grew up near this guy this lame
basketball guy what was it what was that
thing about the odds of becoming a
celebrity
yeah just that
uh there are more
independent artists in the top one
percent of earners than i would have
guessed uh because it does offer this
local monopoly
and trying to become an independent like
trying to be a podcast host or a writer
or things like that
if you're young and you're willing to do
the things that hack your
hack luck to your advantage uh maybe not
a crazy
path so
yeah
seth stevens davidowitz ladies and
gentlemen if people want to keep up to
date with what it is that you're doing
why should they go
i'll definitely buy don't trust your gut
uh and then uh my website is sethsd.com
i love it man i appreciate your work i
like the fact that someone who has the
uh data science chops to be able to ask
all of the big questions that we want
has decided to go and troll through
whatever a thousand
academic papers and a ton of data to do
the the book's brilliant everyone should
go and go and check it out it'll be
linked in the show notes below uh and
looking forward to seeing what you do
next
thanks chris what's happening people
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that episode then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
peace
you